okay we're live
here there's a lot of stuff I want to
get done
today um we're going to probably do some
stuff on this rocket project over the
weekend
here let me see if we did
anything kind
of kind of I have to fix this later um
there are a few things I want to do
today the first big one is there's a
limitation with the new native API that
I would like to fix
potentially um but I also want to
get I want to test a couple potential
bugs that uh people have reporting some
things will re with and I want to see if
we can get uh some of the environments
really polished and training properly
today
me take a quick look for
PRS yeah okay this is I've already
discussed these with contributors um you
don't see it here but it's a lot of the
discussions are in
Discord okay so I think what we're going
to do is we're going to just start with
um the Moa for a bit
let's commit all this stuff up I don't
know what we're going to do with this
build
file um I think we'll just for now
yeah we'll do this for
now and then I think we'll just go over
to uh
MOA and we'll see if we can get some
stuff done there
right whole bunch of new code gets
pulled
the first thing I'm going to want to
probably test is multi- discreete
actions whether these work as expected
oh it's because it's a Sim link that's
fine so I changed it essentially so that
um if RB isn't installs it'll install it
for you and I had something with an old
outdated
name I'm hopeful we can actually make
some good progress on the mob today I
really just want to get puffer to the
point where I have reasonable policies
trained for all these various different
environments um so that like ultra high
perf RL really just starts to feel
stable across a variety of domains I
think I need to do more work on that
side
one of the downsides the new
setup okay so this is squared squared is
a very simple sanity test environment
that trains in
seconds this seems to work
multi
agent
basis so I made this specifically to
test
for weird screwups
Dev Branch I'm allowed to have stuff
break
occasionally okay so this space m does
work on
dev but I thought didn't bet mess with
this
yeah
H why did I think B messed with this
this looks
fine just watch your PhD this this video
on YouTube very interesting congrats on
completing it than thank
you I made uh recently if you're
interested in just a general overview of
RL in a way that is somewhat
entertaining and not like math heavy or
anything I suggest the iceberg video on
my channel I put quite a bit of effort
into making that one
good it didn't catch on as much as my
thesis video but the production value I
think is a bit higher
interest I mean we're really here trying
to now that I've graduated the really
the goal is to just revamp the entire
field um I'm working on that full time
and it's gone very very well so far
things are like 100 to a th times faster
than they were 6 months ago across the
steps I think that this Freez is the
problem right
second environment very
slow it's a
that it appears to be
training I can see just the summary
here we see leveling up we see skill
usage we see Towers being taken looks
like radiant is winning
like okay so we
have a ton of
okay so we do have all of
these we have all these
metrics I don't know if rewards are
going through or
not doesn't look like rewards are being
computed entropy
variance we have good monitoring
here looks
like some form of Elo over
time would be good it's expensive to
compute as the
talk okay though this does look stable
which is
nice the environment is too slow though
so
something something must have happened
with this because this should be
running much much
faster so let's get this policy see what
it
does and then we will go from there yeah
I think that's a good plan for today um
meanwhile we have new breakout
and let me ask Noah
where is breakout and
okay so entropy is all the way down here
this is probably not the best the Run
doesn't look terribly unstable
though let's
see and both sides are taking
Towers it's not completely
one-sided uh for whatever reason dire is
dire has a huge level
Advantage but radiant is
odd let's look at kills
maybe I mean the cool thing with all
these stats right is
get Le
panels
so you can see that just on the
different teams these they're wildly
different uh they are
all going
up Carrie doesn't seem to do very
well the is
op this is almost done training though
so we'll have a little model to play
with we'll see if it does anything
reasonable let's get prepared for that
actually
I think I have to do V native as well
hold
on yeah the new V mode is
native okay so here is a random
policy and can I take
over uh I cannot take over I don't
think no but here we have the
Bots playing randomly
oh this is funny Escape doesn't quit the
whole
bet bet is our resident puffer
Advertiser though do star the repository
it helps us out a
I did a little bit of puffer advertising
this morning
but this uh this has done decently well
for a
morning okay so it's running
evals yeah 1:41 in like three hours
though I think I should get a
that one should be doing quite well for
us we should get like an extra we'll
probably get a good 100 followers off of
a post like
that okay so what happened
here
Len okay so I have to change the script
a little bit not a big deal though
log I have to copy this manually that's
fine
here we
go for
here the fact that they're stuck on the
walls like
this like okay this guy got
through he's ghosting through walls
apparently
is he ghosting through all the walls or
just some
walls does he live
this if he doesn't take a tower shot I
think he dies here
it's weird cuz
like some of the things done are
reasonable why are the rest of these
guys
stuck like it makes no sense right
it makes no sense that they would just
go like this and get
things let's just sanity check a couple
couple environment side things
first these are fine
multi discreete
right then presumably I was smart enough
to do this
correctly 10 *
I 10 * I +
1 is correct
10 agents per
why would why would one agent do okay
and the rest of them get
255 by 255
what about the
mobet extra map
features divide by
255 flat
features get divided by
255 for
I'm not confident that this is a data
problem and I'm not confident that this
isn't just a data
problem that's the thing that's
obnoxious
here let me see
H the only one of these that I can see
that is completely insane
is the uh value function clipping
coefficient and we've seen that happen
across a variety of
environments what happens to the value
function well what happens to the value
that it could just be that this thing
fails
on they are getting
stuck which corresponds to
Star Puffer
indeed do we get any stars actually off
of the latest
um latest post
11:24 I need to keep this trajectory
going straight up though like before I
need to keep promoting it
really helps us to have uh the
growth that's just I need to tweet this
stuff
more all right well what we're going to
do is we're going to try
this uh what do we have for batch
this okay so immediately it's training
way faster with the uh multiprocessing
on does it learn anything
though uhoh is it
stuck huh it's
stuck with multiprocessing on it's
stuck be back later maybe you can help
me fix and d i
sure I get done with
this okay so this should not be
stuck why would it ever be stuck because
of
multiprocessing how does this make
sense I remember this actually being an
issue and I'm trying to think why this
would ever make sense
why would it ever get stuck in stuck
with
multiprocessing do Native for
now and we'll look at this
we'll have to do some work on
that welcome
folks I should probably put this thing
that we're training up on the side so
people can see what we're
doing
today this is a combination of looking
at the new API and trying to make sure
everything works as well as trying to
make this specific mend work
plot okay
so we have MOA before we have MOA after
so this is going to tell us actually
learning
progress uh
we more towers are being taken
immediately level is
up do we have
victories yeah we have some victories
here so I think it's getting wins faster
which which is meaning that it's going
to be you're going to get this
oscillatory
behavior um essentially I want to have a
decently trained MOBA policy today I
just want to have something that like
the Bots run at each other down mid at
the very least you
know we should be able to get that and
if we can't get that that's it's either
a data issue or some sort of infer issue
because as a task it should be very
learnable
send a followup email while this is
training this will be done in a couple
so
what I mean it's not surprising that
this would train way
better I'm trying to think
why we had the hyper parameters from
welcome
H where are other
parameters also why do we
have nine visualize visualize
none and we do
if I ever get bored of doing
reinforcement
learning and I want to get into more
General ml Ops I'm going to rewrite wand
B and C so that it's
okay so this is sketchy um level kept
going up before but now in this run it
doesn't appear to be stable
maybe entropy is staying high in this
run whereas before it was very quickly
crashed value
loss not looking good
which is
Victory hold
on I think this is actually good
because they stopped winning games after
this first point in training before so
probably this is what happened is that
they learned something and they
unlearned stuff because the the Run
wasn't stable whereas now the fact that
this is oscillating around means that
games are starting and stopping so this
could actually be a good
thing
level I don't know why it would go way
back
down we'll have to
see oh you know what I can do in the
meantime I'm kind of curious for
checkpoint so this is from the previous
trained
terrain this guy is stuck
here it's going to use its speed buff to
glitch through the terrain
more oh wait that's a tank that's a tank
engage that's a tank engage learned
right there
AOE okay so it's it started learning
some stuff and then crashed and then
these guys aren't really doing it any
favors being stuck there like
they should be learning to win more
games faster
this oh yeah look at
this games are actually being
ended for
oh look at
this wait whoa whoa they're running at
each other down
anything why is dire team not do
anything
do I have something messed up with like
the action handling for these
handling mean you can learn
policies well now they get
stuck this one doesn't
according to this it does
win and it wins some games
all were they doing anything earlier in
training
bit Yeah so it does look like they're
being controlled correctly learning is
just doing something very weird
here for
at well we're not logging
everything the way we would want to I
also I don't believe
this like look it says it's using its
skills it's going up l
Q let's go look at our logging and the
way we're handling logging I think that
there is some stuff that we need to be
recording
correctly yeah cuz this is going up
infin
Ely we need to get we need to see um we
need to see this a bit
we have to
reset what logs
this this should get us usage uh this
should get us per game logs rather
than cross game
logs and then we're going to have to
make these
barer what happened
now we should get more reasonable stats
out of
uh i' just
say have to run for a little bit
okay so I'll have to integrate this
later this
cool okay you can already see that this
is the curve is different just from this
log yeah so this what my hope it here is
that this is going to actually tell us
um the problem with these
curves well
either of these really make sense I
don't know if either of these really
make sense to be
honest according to this graph the agent
that we were watching on the dire side
should absolutely not just be sitting
there so either the logs are wrong or
something else is
okay so
here it says that this is dealing a ton
of
damage which I don't believe because
it's not actually going anywhere on the
map so this one is going to match
closely to's alive
right these graphs yeah these ones match
pretty much the
same reward XP we need to actually graph
this
kills let's see what's not getting
grafted right
now uh radiant
Ked there like neutral
skill layer log
well this is weird why isn't this
getting logged
yeah these logs are not coming out the
way they're supposed to
be this will finish running we'll pull
this we'll launch this new one see if
that logs and we'll like keep iterating
on logs essentially
and then we'll look for like a metric
that we can optimize a bit
go okay so these guys aren't really
doing
anything well what model did I
copy oh wait I copied um an early
checkpoint in that case that might be
fine so early checkpoint behaves very
much like the previous early
checkpoint and then it's like just
starting to
learn to leave base
this now we can see a lot more
intentionality in leaving the base they
get
stuck and then these guys actually are
staying up
here this could just be like a
directionality bias and that they just
basically learn to go that
way but now I should have better stats
on this because clearly if they're doing
this they're not getting any kills or
anything
right so I should actually be able to
get something out of this
now yeah I should be able to get
something out of
this we can't see neutral kills we still
need that stat
damage
received damage
dealt okay so we have some graphs for
the radiant assassin that it's doing
damage right and then we have
graphs for dire
it says it's still doing damage is the
thing I don't believe
it it's still doing
it let's see if we can fix that uh that
version of stats next
yeah why don't we have
uh that's weird that's very weird
okay so right here we're supposed to
have this neutral kill
field
right tower killed neutral
killed and if I go
to unless it's like the radiant tank
doing
everything I'm pretty
sure you can see it's just not logging
yet
neutral right here is a good spot for a
break point
okay so as soon as a neutral
dies we will get a break
point let's go kill a
neutral aha
we get our break point
out 980 damage delt total
it's more than I dealt just in this one
last tick
right received some
damage looks like a valid log to
log why is it always zero in train
to get cleared
right did I reset it
wrong that wouldn't make a difference
1852 is
right yeah this guy must have killed the
neutral it's
fine we just run down this way we take a
tower I forget this game's actually kind
of fun
and
go okay so here's our M vog
right and
optimized
out but we can see n logo one is
there was my aggregate function
clear oh I'm just missing the
uh I'm just missing some stuff
here
[Music]
H maybe that one doesn't get
logged I think I found most likely the
cause of this just a logging
okay right here all these
metrics these are these need to be
adjusted XP distance
Tower uh level kills deaths damage dealt
received and now this is we're just
missing all the kill stats
we also missed Auto usage so wait this
is creeps
neutrals
level and we're ready for a new
experiment
here ladders
misleadingly oh I think I got
that okay always use um early
braces and I know why for some reason I
thought it was a good idea not to have
them logging part of the RL
algorithm or for metrics and
troubleshooting uh it's for metrics and
troubleshooting
mostly like honestly reinforcement
learning is easy getting um getting data
out of
simulations in a way that is correct and
transparent is hard
that's become increasingly obvious the
further I get along and
puffer like the reason that RL is hard
is because of complete and utter lack of
engineering and logging and things like
this okay so here's our next
experiment hope hopefully this
runs and now we should be getting
additional
logs this is just a
subset so here are some runs that we had
from
before and if I refresh this and for
newcomers to the stream I see some
people just
joined um this is the game
environment that we are currently
working on and doing reinforcement
learning with it's like a strip down
League of Legends or DOTA Style game
it's got a few different classes they've
got different abilities you can play it
it's kind of fun it needs animations and
stuff
still whoa
whoa look at
that so here this wasn't being logged
before now we can actually see this
thing is actually csing
you can see it's autoing you can see all
sorts of
stuff yeah this is very cool actually
look very early in
training this thing's just been training
for like two minutes or whatever no this
thing's been training for 40 seconds and
uh it's already killing
neutrals we're starting to get some
rewards as well
tow
killed
perfect so I'm going to go get a yeah
nice it charts it all out yeah literally
we have look at the number of metrics
I'm logging here you see I'm logging
actually hundreds of metrics cuz I have
I have um 19 metrics at the moment for
each of 10 different agents it's like
400 metrics and then there's some Global
ones so we can kind of see right like
look I'm made these changes now we can
see how this works out on the graphs
it's very
nice this experiment is going to take
six or so minutes to run uh this
actually should be running twice as fast
but we have a few bugs to fix with
vectorization I think in this
n I'm going to let this run I'm going to
go grab a cup of tea use the rest from
real quick and then we're going to see
if we can't figure out why this is uh
the behaviors that we're seeing don't
seem to match the learning charts we be
right
okay
what do we have
refresh one
B
uhuh how the turns
table you see the
problem look now we can see clearly what
we couldn't see
before it stops far fing here completely
stops farming these neutrals
almost and if we look at dire
side but like dire
assassin yeah it just stops doing stuff
right
so the run is not
stable I think it's both sides right we
saw it was both
sides both sides
assassin yeah look it's Autos drop a
whole bunch
level level actually keeps
up still getting Tower
kills actually reward XP went up which
is
weird well I guess the rant is the one
that actually keeps kind of doing stuff
huh it stops farming
neutrals overall does not look
particularly stable
I don't know if can we see anything in
the
losses okay
so clip Frack is
fine
entropy doesn't really
budge the policy loss
increasing no potentially tells
us explain variance increasing it could
just be an unstable
just be decreas decreased learning rate
or
something at least now we can see
clearly
what about
rewards I'm going look at some
rewards so the dire carry doesn't really
get anything
ever radiant carry also not looking
great
radiant assassin is very mobile does
actually get some XP and actually the XP
reward continues to go
up as well as Tower taking so really the
the assassin class is carrying here uh
you can see that the
tank the tank learns a bunch and then
stops kind of just
crashes support
gets a little XP not
much burst
character so reward keeps going
see dire
tank this keeps going
up how does this keep going
up I guess it's drops at the
end let's go grab like a pretty late
checkpoint
me so there was one obnoxious thing that
I wanted to reply to I saw briefly on my
phone
oops where did it
go
P this is like a relatively
late checkpoint in our short little
train run
and
okay now keep in mind this is like
they've been trained for a few minutes
so like they're going to be kind of
Spazzy we just want to see them like
generally go down
mid so the Assassin character looks to
be doing what we
want it's going to dash in take this
Camp take some of the
camp me they are kind of spazy and non
committ going to get
XP there is the opposing
tank so actually that's not bad these
guys are stuck in
base but uh we did actually see the
enemy tank coming on over
is
interesting so I don't think we're like
completely on the wrong track here I
think we're in a decent
Direction and we just have to figure out
what it is that's preventing these guys
from uh from
try first of all I want to take a look
at what I just want to confirm what one
thing welcome YouTube
here this is the whole
file uh I want to confirm
tile map
grid we do have walls here so they
should actually they should be able to
see when they're walking into
something what's my Moet what's the Moet
look like
project so this is the hidden Dimensions
here are kind of troll I
think I might have trolled here
let me try to mess with the network
sizes real quick this is just like a
quick
YOLO
uh quick like YOLO thing
runs so thinking was um we just have a
really tiny hidden
dims I'm curious to see if the uh if the
train graph
changes
substantially so this
about a little more than doubled the uh
number of parameters in the network here
it's still very small we'll still be
able to run this on web but I'm curious
to
see whether this uh makes a difference
we'll get the result for this in here in
just a few
minutes we'll take a look at it early on
as
well um for folks that are new around
here the mob is currently published it's
in the dev
Branch I'll link this here if you want
to help me out go ahead and Star Puffer
helps a
ton you can also play it online same
game we have like some not particularly
well trained bots in here uh that we're
going to try to improve on today but
like it's it's kind of like leag or DOTA
right You've Got A qw and E scale it's
different for every class and what's
this guy do he do
I think the clam is the one that has
yeah this is this one has like a
force I'm going to try to get some
reasonable policies trained for
these okay
so that looks different
already I don't know whether it's
meaningfully
different where are
our where the aggregated
metrics okay
Victory
H we'll change the graph a
bit I don't know whether it's a
substantial change
Sol have this sort of
cyclical Behavior
here the question is really about
whether this is more
stable you doing box one I'm on box zero
now Spencer you're good go do some
experiments I have but I have a there's
a puffer
box like zero that I use uh as default
if I need more I'll tell
good yeah it would be good to get that
environment going as well I'm trying to
get the Moa into a good spot at the
moment we really just need these
environments to ship frankly like as
soon as we ship uh the next puffer
update that's really the prerequisite
for catapulting RL into modern
era we just need the m to be like known
good with baselines
right they don't even have to be bug
free you just have to be able to learn
something interesting within them uh to
a point that like it's useful and we can
you know we can ship patches
thereafter but they need to be
stable pong is pretty much stable as is
right now connect for as soon as we have
a better opponent policy if Jack does
that we'll be uh we'll be
good we need some sort of greedy thing
for triple
Triad you know some sort of opponent for
go need to be
fast Noah has a couple things on
breakout that I will just integrate
whenever
mhm what bugs haven't heard of
him well
the M's get to be
complicated I don't know if I'm going to
be happy or disappointed if this
experiment
works this experiment working would just
be the Run somehow being more stable
I don't even know if that's a reasonable
expectation do we look at losses
here the thing that made me suspicious
is like 32 hidden dim is really low oh
there's Jake not Jack
Jake end the weekend
awesome yeah it doesn't have to be
perfect we mainly just needs to we want
to be able to train like a decent
Connect 4 agent as well
1 2 3 4 5
six plus secret M that I'm working on
makes seven wait no wait four 5 six
seven makes eight plus go makes nine
plus pick any of the other Ms we finish
one other one of the other Ms we've got
TCG needs to get going
to lots of
stuff really I'm enjoying learning C
it's really nice
frankly I swear it's like if you've been
working in higher level languages for a
while it's it's like all of modern
software engineering is kind of just a
lie C is just really easy and
comfortable and fast
I don't know if you're terminally online
on Twitter or not but um there are all
these dumb posts about like akusha or
whatever this like hallucinogen is just
ruining people's lives and like making
them do dumb stuff well uh I didn't take
any hallucinogens but I am going to say
like I ran a 50k and then 3 days after
that when I started coding I just just
basically went straight into C I went
from 10 years of python to doing
everything in C so I don't know if
there's a correlation
there maybe it's uh less masochistic
after you do something far more
masochistic but I've actually I've never
been happier with Dev
like these M's just feel good to write
MC
geez I don't know we'll see maybe after
the next athletic goal then I'll start
doing
Cuda I'm considering trying to deadlift
uh 405 for their first time in two years
later today we'll see how that
goes I basically took two years off from
doing very very serious lower body
strength training in order to do the
running stuff and now I'm trying to get
them both at the same time so I can be
hybrid big Tech stack minimal Tech stack
yeah I really like the minimal Tech
stack I really really don't like when
stuff is too complicated for you to know
how everything works all at the same
time and like Dev just slows down it's
no longer enjoyable like you've got to
enjoy your work and like if
uh know if stuff gets too slow I just
stop enjoying it and I stop being
productive so it's like the focus on
Simplicity in some way it's not just
like a a choice it's like required in
order for me to get the stuff
done to see have good neuronet training
inference libraries like pytorch sensor
flow it has an inference Library cuz I
wrote
yaml for kubernetes in a few
months uh you know probably just shoot
me before that
happens here here's puffer N.H 500 line
inference Library compatible with
pytorch in
C can ignore the allocator stuff we
don't even use these you got weights you
got an ability to load a flat P torch
file you've got sigmoid re linear comms
lstms one hot concatenate argmax with a
multi- discreete soft Max multi-
discreete sample you got a bunch of
stuff less than 300 lines and then
there's some bindings just for
convenience so it's kind of funny when
it's like oh this but you don't have
this like library right you need like an
inference Library you can just write one
it'll take you a couple days and you can
just do
it this stupid con function was not easy
to
write the rest of it wasn't that
bad you've been productive I try to be I
don't know the productivity comes in
Cycles I got to really capitalize you
know when I'm like on I really got to
capitalize and get a lot done
I'm not so sure about the rocket thing I
was doing yesterday it's you might have
been right it's kind of a waste but hey
I mean I got a new potential
collaborator out of it so if I get to
spend uh if I got to spend a Saturday
trying to like sit down and fix a rocket
EMP with somebody new that'll be
funny saying no shame in switching well
I mean that's what it means right it's
like I don't know if it was if it's
worth the
effort like I essentially I'm going to
do physics stuff at some point
um
but the question is essentially just how
much of a pain it is going to be to work
with the physics libraries and such to
get stuff working
nicely I did get box 2D running at 250k
steps per second though
and I think we can and that was on my
local so we can go way faster than that
probably get a
million
here what do we think happened do we
think bigger neural networks are magic
or do we think RL on small neural
networks is
magic it's still dropping towards the
end here but not anywhere near as
level's
higher a little
bit but
dire is this dire
assess oh
yeah huh what about this dire
tank it still
drops not Magic
model this one should be big enough to
learn something at
what about these
guys you're getting out of the
base they're not like hard running into
the wall at
least here comes the
Assassin oh assassin
battle H you're under Tower my
friend probably Tower diving level one
is not the best strategy
H there goes the Tank tank versus burst
under tower Tower diving level one not a
good
idea but I mean this is closer to what
we
want there're like some of these guys
are still stuck in
base I don't know why you would be stuck
in base there's like no reason to be in
base there's nothing for you
there let's see if we can figure out
um there's like a reward reason for
death okay look it just falls
off you see apparently the support was
going out before and it stopped so
there's got to be some reason it learned
to stop going
it actually started at the at the uh the
start here it was actually
CSM
[Music]
reward I mean the reward is just so
sparse right
it's not getting like a consistent
signal or maybe it's the fact that this
is this is a tiny tiny
reward it shouldn't be tiny I think it's
just
rare reward
Tower it's not getting penalized for
death I don't think
it actually should
be reward death is negative
death This should now be good
[Music]
all
right baseship catching we got a little
end working uh we need to run sweeps and
fix some stuff on it though one be free
for those types of metric yeah I think I
technically pay them a little
bit but
yeah W is pretty good they need to
rewrite this thing faster at some point
like that's the only complaint is it
needs to be the UI just needs to be
faster with when you have a bunch of
metrics and
C make all of wand be a Raab like a Raab
UI that'd be
fun okay so we have the this metric here
um you know what I want to try let me
try
something I wonder if the death reward
is the thing that's SC it up cuz I
wasn't logging it
zero so now you're literally you just
get a reward for getting XP and you get
a reward for taking Towers yeah and then
this is 01 so like 50 reward would give
you 0.05 reward XP something like that
uh where's learning rate 05 yeah let's
let's let's try
this because something is
causing like some of the characters to
learn to stay in base and it could just
be that they're like well my character
is weak and I die a lot so maybe I just
stop doing it you
know maybe they're smart and uh the
rewards are dumb you
know thank you to our resident
Advertiser bet here um yeah do Star
Puffer Leb if you uh if you're
interested in the project at all it
really does help a
lot basically the only two channels
where uh I promote work and show stuff
off we've got the puffer GitHub here and
then also uh if you are doing RL
stuff I mean I do Post resources on X as
well for instance just
today this little quick start
guide literally a one weekend guide to
getting into reinforcement
learning basically if you are new and
you do this stuff you and you have an
engineering background uh you will
already be able to contribute usefully
to RL and to puffer and to all these fun
PhD
yeah well that's the fun
thing H you do get good support on this
stuff contributors actually get quite a
bit
of quite a bit of input
on learning
stuff and people actually learn quite a
bit very fast
here I wanted to make like some meme
right where like puffer Li contributors
like you know you type in GitHub you
start typing an issue it's already
answered you start typing in Discord
it's already answered you like get tired
and you like queue up a game of League
like puffer has joined as your support
but then I realized I'm too bad at that
game to actually do
that spending too much time freaking
writing all the code on this
thing yeah literally though you get like
a support thing with puffer you say okay
I'm tired for the night nope
all the RL stuff but it's just
you
okay
so um is something happening
here I can't tell
I
mean I can't think of any reason why
specific characters would stay in base
if you don't have a penalty for dying
what's wrong with the Moa um I mean we
have stuff that's training but like
they're kind of weird right
like they first they all start going
down mid and then some of the characters
just decide that they're going to stop
doing that and they stay in base and
then like just the Assassin and the tank
which are probably the two strongest
characters go down mid at each other so
I think that
probably it's the death uh the death
penalty is the
problem like the negative reward for
dying
post actually is doing very
well people like RL
guides negative rewards
yeah see oh I think this
is this looks better to me right this
looks more consistent already oh yeah
there it is we fixed it
folks you see that
we took away the penalty for
dying and now the support will actually
play the game
um I don't know about the hugging face
stuff is the hugging face course
good I don't know how their code is
[Music]
uh yeah I don't
know the only thing is I don't know how
their code
is oh they use clean RL oh of course
they use clean RL because Costa was at
hugging face for a while yeah okay yeah
totally then this is
good this is good
this is a good because
Costa so the reason I wasn't sure is
because like some of the hugging face
engineering is a bit dodgy like it's
just overbuilt and over
complicated um but yeah if cost if they
use cleaner stuff it's
great anybody else follow serpent AI was
building an RL yeah I think
um I looked at this and I think that
it's not going to be fast enough Jake
like the games aren't going to run fast
enough is they going to be the problem
do you know tiny grad yeah I know of
tiny grad I haven't tried it yet because
it's newer
um and I don't know about not having
fast eager mode and having to do
everything compiled but I'm keeping my
eye on it it looks very nice we'll
probably end up buying some tiny boxes
in the future as
puffer play is nice it plays as nice as
it can play with
compile ooh so what happened here the
reward went back down
right this did way better but then it
still
it's almost
trained we'll be able to watch this
model and see how this plays I think
this should be getting closer to what I
was trying to do I just basically all I
want to do today is I want to train a
basic model that run where the teams
will learn to at least run down mid at
each other and maybe like Farm some
camps I want to just like have a decent
enough model to put on the website just
like so that we know that the uh the
environment is not completely broken
that we're getting good logs and that we
can use this for
research that's the main
yeah this looks
better what about the
support the support seems like it's
didn't
learn man the support was
learning why did the support
stop I mean it didn't complete
completely
stop
huh let's just see the the model maybe
it's decent
okay here's the new
model let's see what these guys are
doing uh the Assassin is starting to get
out of Base
gu starting to get out of
here okay assassin and tank are starting
to do
things they're going to look Spazzy like
this for a while early in training
especially without uh good hyper
parameters so that's fine the question
is just do they go down okay yeah
there's our burst our burst is like
farming waves in
mid tank is slowly getting there
maybe the walls are also one tile off in
the renderer which is why they're kind
of
glitching support and carry aren't
really doing
much oh okay we have a we've got a tower
fight here we've got two siing First
Tower and
then we've got a 2v2
here
oh that's legit
still not quite as good as I want uh as
I'm looking
for but this is like closer to the right
direction this is not like it's not
clearly being stupid
it's like looks like it's getting into
the right
direction interestingly you can
see are there any instabilities in the
train
run there might just be some
instabilities in the
training oops
okay so here we can
see
level the policy loss going up like that
is
sketchy and the policy loss going up
like that is sketchy
I think
why why it would be doing
this we just do we have too large of a
learning rate like
what why would this be
happening you can see the training is
just
not policy law should not be going up
like that even though that's very small
it's consistent what about
value oh yeah look we have value lost
Spike right
reasonable what do we have as batch size
here
think wait num Ms is
four how does that make sense
400 so
4K hold
short I think I did this for Speed and
then forgot to
to adjust
works oh wait this is also a crazy ratio
isn't
it 256k to 16k like this is a crazy
ratio
do let's do like
64k how many updates is this no that's
still crazy that's 16 updates
I'm going to do
this let's do like
this I bet you this this this fixes
stability let's
see this should at least improve
stability it might tank the training
speed we'll
what do we think the train curves will
look
like for
folks this was the policy I had before
right yeah so I think we're already
better than
this how long do training take just a
few minutes and it should be even
shorter we got to fix some stuff with
vectorization let's do just the last
three runs I think or the last yeah
let's just take these off got too many
runs yeah so you can see
here the training speed is tanked
based on what I just
did oh wait this steps thing hold on the
steps might be different I don't even
know why it is
on steps for everything it should be
on
agent should be on agent
steps what the hell is wrong with this
section
[Music]
mil actually it's weird cuz the dire
level is not going up very quickly but
radiant is about the same as it was
before what about
individual individual Rewards
usually radiant assassin is the easiest
to
learn okay so it's hard to say I think
it just takes it could just be taking
longer to get
started which would make sense cuz
you're doing fewer
updates but um The Hope is that it'll be
actually stable
as soon as we get something
stable uh I'm going to switch over to
just fixing figuring out what is wrong
with vectorization that way we can run
this at a proper
speed I mean by proper speed I mean this
is already running about a 100 times
faster than it would normally be in
Academia it's just not running at 300
times normal which is what we want
360,000
which I forget if I made this run at
five steps per second at 10 steps per or
10 steps per second but it's either
15,000 or 30,000 times realtime
speed it's still over it's still playing
like more it's still playing more games
of uh of this than I've played of League
every minute
so how much League have I played I
couple hundred
much oh look at
that this is starting to take
off right here
it's starting to take
towers and get
stable the only thing that would really
surprise me here is if this ends up
being both worse and less stable
lower
value our value is still clean
but this is not like perfectly
stable I mean it is entering a high
learning like a high learning Pace
regime we will see this is still a whole
bunch of updates is the
thing this is still a ton of
updates we might end up having to do a
weight accumulation or no wait grading
accumulation we'll see do you even need
mini batches you need them because of
memory we might end up needing to do um
gradient
accumulation welcome YouTube
folks currently running experiments on
this MOA here trying to get some
reasonable
SMI 23%
so we can probably go up a
bit oh no wait duh it's like a
quarter well we still do need mini
batches bet cuz then we could only go up
to like 250 K I think that's still too
small for the
batch cuz like here I'll do a quick RL
tutorial on
this this is a very important and not
often made
point with
RL so the way that RL works right you're
collecting your agent
trajectories your agent trajectories
look like this right you have like
T1 T2
you know and then this is you you have
to collect a batch of data um so let's
say that you're going to have 8,000
agents because you have 800 copies of
the environment which is what I have
because that's what's effective for the
hardware then so I have 8K agents and I
do
256k batch size well then when I go to
optimize this I'm not going to have a
really long trajectory cuz I'm going to
have on average 250
8K per
agent right and uh I don't know what's
this
32 which is
short so ideally if we have 8K
environments we would like to have
512k or uh a
million batch size which is not going to
fit in memory which means you either
have to mini batch or you have to do
grading to
okay well value loss actually stayed
stable length
32 yeah the segments because you need to
do generalized Advantage estimations
you're Computing reward across segments
like that uh and it's just really that's
not long enough okay but look though we
have this stable looking
level
here episode length going down is
actually probably good
I want to look at some of these
rewards hey Spencer one second let
me using latest go changes increasing
size of board 5x five and up one each
time still solving M just taking
longer increase Forex looks like just
taking longer to realize that bad does
figure it out eventually yeah that makes
total sense so get training to a million
steps per second right and we tune hyper
parameters and then it figures that out
quicker probably
right I don't know about this reward
here
is this guy not doing anything let me
see it's getting some
kills well it is actually taking more
Towers it looks like
n this is not stable like
look it's not
[Music]
farming I don't think this is farming as
here let's go look at the policy anyways
though
assassin we see our burst on the right
migrating out over to the rest of the
map what do we think over here up yep
there 's their assassin and their
got oh there's our tank farming some
camps that's
cool the training stability is very
important
on radiant
assassin yeah this should be
consistently going up
crazy well actually is it
crazy what I do for Atari
something
28 can you fit 256k in
here and like
1024 can I fit this
looks like you can fit
this 1 million batch size
250k this is with the bigger model as
well that's
nice 42% on the
n because we don't have vectorization so
we can actually uh shove this up to like
500k pretty
easily main thing I'm looking for is
stability of
losses policy loss is not in a good spot
and explain
variances
yeah clip Frack is okay
but now the value loss is technically
okay but it is
increasing maybe this will be more
stable cuz it doesn't look like we have
a learning problem it looks like we've
got a stability
problem we also should change the way
that we're recording logs a
bit we're recording too
frequently was there reward hold
on
reward yeah look the reward for XP is
just not consistent increasing
here or
unstable I think we also probably have
I mean we can manually do a couple of
these parameters just for
now I can probably guess decent
off where's our
run already have 60
mil okay
so
now
okay there's some
stable Lambda and Gamma are going to
be interesting
probably will change a little
bit the current parameters that we're
using for
this gamma's
97 lambda's 995
interpretation Lambda probably goes to
0.
see too early to say use the restroom
grab more tea and uh we'll be back doing
more of
H well that looks that's
something I don't know the thing is I
don't know if it's going to actually
be
hm a weird
curve what about this
know this could be it this could just
take way longer but be more stable I
wouldn't be
surprised 200 mil train is not enough on
this well we haven't messed hold on we
haven't messed with J parameters yet
so we still we're not out of
here but yeah presumably this is just it
has so many fewer updates
right of course cuz like in reality we
don't actually need to have a batch size
this ridiculous right at least not early
in training uh the reason that we have a
batch size like this is because of
Hardware
constraints so yeah it's just not going
to be it's going to it's like oh 200
million samples should be enough but no
not with these settings because it's
only like 200 uh it's 800 total gradient
steps yeah it's not a
lot and it is starting to increase
pretty much all the different
metrics so we'll do um
J G parameter
next we'll be
good change that to
well and we'll see if that makes a
difference
I think we're getting close
though to like finding something that
makes a relatively consistent
performance improvements I mean we're
not looking for a crazy model right
we're just trying to
show the things run at each other down
mid they like you expect that they
should learn to at least run at each
other down mid maybe take some camps and
throw their abilities at each other
right
what happened to
my what happened to my
oh
okay I mean it kind of did
something I guess we just need to look
at
losses we can do that once we launch the
new one
though
oops gamma goes to 095 from
995 learning
rate learning rate
increase probably learning rate can
increase do I want to risk doing both
these at once not
really do you have a reward for damage
dealt we have a reward for gaining
experience policy on I I'll tell you in
a second hold on got to sleep have a
productive day thank you thanks for
dropping by
by feel free to stop by the Discord we
do uh if you want to get involved with
contributing we got a lot of Ms to build
on okay so this is now the je parameter
uh I'm going to go pour this cup of tea
and I'll tell you about um reward
shaping and how to do that be right
[Music]
back
I forgot to unmute my
mic
um let me go through
reward
shaping yeah I just realized
that let me talk about reward shaping
so you don't want to be in a spot where
you're like manually tuning reward
components for weeks on end for a hard
problem and like tune reward like tweak
reward run experiment tweak reward run
experiment that's a mess you want to be
in a place where you have like a bunch
of different reward component weights
and you have a very fast environment and
then you run a giant hyperparameter
sweep that includes automatically tuning
the weights of those
rewards um that's where you want to
be and that's actually what I did
originally with
this the time that you start tuning
parameters at all like I'm doing at the
moment is basically when you have a new
environment where the environment might
have bugs there might be other things
wrong and you're essentially just
playing with it in order to try to
understand how it works and how it
responds to stuff um you want to use
this sparingly but it's a good way to
debug stuff um so yeah that's what I'm
doing at the
moment and I have a few different reward
components for this project uh but
actually there are only two of them that
are enabled right now they get a reward
for getting experience that's
proportional to experience gained and
they get a a pretty high constant reward
for taking a tower that's it
what do you tune against in the sweep
like a few
higher yeah you just come up with some
components of like yeah this is probably
relevant right like if I think of a MOA
right it's like okay probably taking
Towers like getting kills getting
experience or gold or whatever stuff
like that just come up with a few
components and then let the uh the hyper
parameter sweep figure out how much they
matter or
don't would you encourage people to do a
PhD in pure
RL
um if you were going to do a PhD already
RL is a perfectly good area of research
yeah
it's like it's going to be a valuable
area um the alternative is you can go
jump on the language model boat with
everybody else already doing
that but like we've got enough people
doing that already we don't have enough
people working on smaller subfields of
AI that like could potentially have a
much larger proportional
impact I forgot to make this experiment
run for
longer uh it looks like it's doing
something
though
yeah that's why I phrased it as if
you're going to do a
PhD can you tune hyper parameters for
the rewards how can you compare yeah so
what you need is you need a success
metric so like let's say that your
training something to play Breakout or
whatever the metric you're tuning
against is score in the game like
overall score you could have a reward
for hitting the ball back you can have
the reward like a negative reward for
hitting the top you can do whatever you
want but then the final thing you care
about is the score so that's what you
use to compare it gets harder in this
environment which is this MOA here right
um in competitive games you need
something like ELO which we have
implemented it's just a bit of a pain
thinking about it currently doing time
series Foundation
models plan on using those in decision
Transformer applied for drone
control do you have a ton of offline
data decision Transformers for offline
data
thing hard to find Labs doing pure
RL there are
few I mean look it depends on what your
priorities are right in my mind if
there're a bunch of people doing a thing
I have no interest in doing it cuz like
it's going to get solved with or without
me right I get interested in like Niche
long shot bet area is where like if I'm
right you can totally change
everything we can generate data yeah but
like online RL is a process for
generating data it depends if you have a
simulator onlineer RL is very very
powerful because your agent gets to
expand its own distribution of data
offline RL is basically just supervised
learning right it's like it's imitation
learning plus a little bit that's
all it's uh in my mind it's like an
entirely different thing like I like the
portion of RL I care about I really
don't even care about the specific
algorithms for RL or the math or any of
it the portion of RL that I think is
most likely to be useful and interesting
is the part that you are gathering your
own data and learning interactively
you're learning in like this very
natural trial and error way and that's
something that's just not the case in
the rest of all of AI so that's what I
see in
it time will tell whether I'm
right but it has already done some
pretty darn cool things it's done so
like a thousandth of the scale of uh the
rest of
AI it's interesting that this thing is
getting XP just very slowly
is this actually worse than
before can't
tell it looks worse than
before that's very weird
on yeah neither of these are good to be
honest neither of these are very good
Foundation models for a classical
problem but like why
though one of the great advantages of
reinforcement learning is it's for
settings where you have a fast simulator
you have unlimited data
your foundation model
cannot train on unlimited data it's too
big you run out of compute you can train
RL on more data than all of gp4 on one
performance you don't need a lot of
compute in RL you just need a fast
simulator
score some tiny boxes down the line what
would you do with the GPU well we would
need to have a parallel GPU trainer by
then essentially the plan is that
eventually RL is going to have enough
environments that run fast enough that
you can saturate all the gpus on a
multi-gpu box just using the CPU cores
that are on that box for simulation so
like let's say that I get if I really
optimize each GPU
we could get um over a million train
steps per second per GPU so with six of
them we have 6 million train steps per
second per GPU and like at that pace you
know you're training faster than all of
opening I5 is but on one little com like
one little box instead of on a massive
cluster you just chunk through tons and
tons of data
they're not useful until we have the uh
the multi-gpu training for
though which has not been a priority
because like there's so much room for
improvement even on single card and the
hardware is very cost
effective like even a lot of Industry
problems you can solve them on one
this cab base Sims no
you can have Cuda Bas Sims if you want
sure it'll work there just as well but
uh fast CPU Sims are good too we're
basically we can Implement stuff plenty
fast on CPU now the way I've been doing
stuff with
puffer how are you funding puffer is the
only a full-time
Dev puffer is my company I uh I finished
my PhD six months
ago so I'm working on this full-time
other people are contributing stuff uh
open source all the stuff is open source
we just officially launched uh business
side of this a few weeks ago the plan is
to be uh providing extended support and
priority features and things like that
for
companies so the idea is hey are you a
company trying to do RL for something
important and having a hard time of it
give puffer a
call we'll get you set up with puffer
which is all open source and free you're
not going to be tied to any proprietary
Tech but you get experienced eyes on the
problem you get prioritized features for
anything that you might need for your
specific
problem that's the
idea you already get to use it in a real
live application
nope brand new company we have a couple
um couple potential clients I'm chatting
with at the moment uh we'll be building
that side out more but a lot of this is
early stage like just building awesome
tech for RL and that's been going pretty
well like you can see all these on
puffer GG these run very fast some of
them are kind of complex we've got a
couple more in the works as well and
there's a lot of nice Tooling in Puffer
lot a lot of nice tooling and puffer for
making stuff
easier like this whole field of RL uh in
the dev branch of puffer right now is
100 to a thousand times faster than it
is in the rest of
Academia and the idea is that when you
have all these this ability to test
stuff so quickly on a number of
different problems some of which are
easy some of which are not so easy you
can be very very confident in the
approaches that you're taking so like if
you decide that you need to do you have
like a new algorithm or a new thing that
needs to be tested on your fancy
production environment that's going to
be slow well what you can do is you can
evaluate it comprehensively on a big
Suite of different tasks um and you can
do that very
efficiently without needing a giant
cluster and then if your method is
actually good then you can then transfer
that to
prod and then you know that the actual
the bigger run is worth doing
the ability to test stuff like that
really doesn't exist in RL right now and
uh it's a huge huge source of cost and
time
sync obviously we do a bunch of other
stuff a bunch of other things with the
puffer Tech but that's one of the big
ones right
now just came across your page looking
to start L my computer can't handle it
saving but I also need to save a lot
because international student school
fees yeah that's a rough one um
I will say RL is pretty fast like you
can do like you can do environment side
work um without needing really any
compute resources it just depends on
engineering background and the
like like some of these M's here this
one's built by a contributor this one's
built by a different contributor these
two are built by yet another contributor
this TCG I made a prototype of and now
we have contributors looking at it these
two are mine
into we also occasionally provide
hardware for specific projects we've got
a little very small little cluster
here all right can I figure out what is
wrong with this experiment now
what's your goal with puffer are you
planning on hiring I'm planning on
hiring once we are profitable like once
we have revenue from uh a few clients
and we need more people to handle more
of
them the goal yes also for multi-agent a
lot of our stuff is multi-agent
um the primary goal for puffer is to
revolutionize the field of reinforcement
learning in order to do that you know
the secondary goal there is to be a
small profitable industry lab that does
open source
work yeah that's the goal have like a
small profitable industry lab that does
a bunch of Open Source work and fixes
the
field that's my goal for
puffer now it's very interesting to
see that with this run the actual the
skill usage is very
good why is the reward kn good if the
skill usage is
good I'm
confused this doesn't make
low for reference Yanick my um my thesis
is on neural was on neural MMO so like
massively multi-agent is kind of my
thing
thing I've been making some single agent
environments because you know a lot of
problems don't need
it but
um yeah that's that's where I originally
started and a lot of the stuff in puffer
makes multi-agent just as easy as single
agent I built a lot of stuff explicitly
to handle multi-agent
well where is it using all these
abilities oh it's
farming wait How's It farming well this
is kind of crazy isn't
it why is the reward so low if it's
farming this
policy I have a Quant project with
ML did that an intership parameter
optimization and PC to run it properly
someday takes me 4 hours to run one test
and sometimes would fail at hour three
yeah that's rough do you think companies
like Riot use RL in back in for bounce
test I know that they do is it hard even
too hard for them it is hard for them
but it's hard for them because they have
uh they are using Ray no they're using
rib for a lot of it at least they used
to be I don't know if they're still
doing it RB is a god aul Library I
actually tried to pitch them on um on
doing something with puffer though that
was like I was still a PhD stage student
and it was way earlier
stage I was originally going to make
puffer uh game focused but I decided it
would be better to have puffer be more
broadly RL for whatever application and
we still use games a lot but mainly we
use we use games for RL more than we use
RL for games if that makes sense we use
games as tests for reinforcement
learning cuz they're fun to implement
they are very very fast and uh they're
very easy to interpret which many other
types of Sims are not so we'll add more
specific industry simulators as we go
forward but games are a really nice core
test
set rip
Rita yeah I don't actually know if
they're still doing stuff
I'm pretty happy with how puffer's gone
so far though like we have actually sped
up reinforcement learning 100 to a th000
fold we have a variety of environments
some of which are already nice and
stable others of which are still in
production but are looking
good we've gotten a nice community of
users and contributors it's a very fast
growing project um we've solved a ton of
the problems that were virtually
impossible just a few months ago it's
been going
well I'd say we're definitely on Pace
up if you found the Pu recor is getting
settled in regarding rppo cm is mostly
it's n work uh it's n work because
there's no point of doing algorithm work
when everything is this slow in
RL like you can't tell if one algorithm
is better than another like you can't
run enough tests like literally like
we're going to end up redoing the last
10 years worth of orl research because
the majority of Publications are wrong
it's actually that
doing okay so they're
farming working I'd be up for working on
a more busy
environment envin Cuda for European
space agen torso decomposition challenge
be a lot slower than most
M's yeah M speed is the tough
one like resources go up proportionally
if M are
farming is it easy to write a game I
made an environment for German card game
although it was made for gymnasium yeah
very easy
um I mean no easier than like no easier
or harder than it would be to write on
its own normally like we have this here
I made a basic template for a card game
that we're going to be expanding on kind
of Magic the Gathering right we can play
a land do this we can like attack let's
see play this this
swing um uh
this and this two four
six and I think we got a
block and
four two
two and I
win yeah so you can look at the code for
these they're on uh the GitHub St the
puffer it's in Dev
we have to do RL for that one still but
it'll be very easy to
bind well I thought for Speed you'd
write it in yeah we write our M's in
C but like it's
easy so here's the Moa the MOBA that
I've been working on right now here's
the entire source for it it's 2,000
lines it's C just pure
c um where's the
TCG the TCG prototype that you just
TCG yeah TCG is like 500
lines I technically have a LinkedIn
though actually it's kind of funny I've
stopped updating it cuz all the business
stuff these days comes off of
X funny
enough like literally all of the
uh all the business stuff comes off of X
these
days Jake going to look at building
industry adjacent Ms that are open
source after I get a baseline done
either that or TCG yeah industry Ms are
good next time I log into LinkedIn I
have to like update everything H that
site is a mess I haven't updated like
any of my my profiles on stuff other
than x I'm actually I'm live on X as
well well right now it's multi streamed
this is the
xlink I do Post quite a bit of stuff on
here about reinfor it's all like RL
stuff right it's a professional
account I try not to get bored and post
random stuff too
often all right what are these guys
doing so this guy got level
three oh it's just he's just chilling
around base and like farming
bad it's just hasn't optimized well it's
been stable at
least here let me just whoops let me
make a longer run
and then we'll do some stuff in the
meantime while this uh this while this
works actually let's make your
commit piix some logs thanks Dylan uni
trying to have reach for future
opportunities need to be more active on
X yeah X is really good for
ML yeah we do uh all all of the stuff is
on like the open source stuff is on
discord.gg puffer
um I mean we have people that have just
joined like in the last few weeks it's a
really good way to learn this stuff
quickly because you do a lot of
engineering side stuff building
environments you learn some RL in the
process of doing that you get a lot of
feedback both from myself and from all
the other people working on it it's like
a very fun and fast-paced thing and like
it's not a giant code base it's a very
small code base it's very easy to work
on like a small specific like
environment or whatever um
yeah you even get
um people that contribute like
environments also get cluster access
once they like if they're like actively
contributing
stuff bet here who is star Zerg in the
chat works on uh Pokemon reinforcement
learning we've got Spencer who was here
earlier is done is currently working on
go uh BET's doing Enduro stuff as well
at the moment what else is in here uh
Noah has a breakout and clone Nathan's
got like this MMO combat M that he's
been working on lots and lots of
stuff let's see if we can figure out
what the heck is wrong with
vectorization
here I got a bit frustrated with RL so
much comes down to how you design your
neural
network example for 20
48 yeah but the thing is
like I have the experience on that side
of things um and you can really just
automate all of the experiments if the
en is fast like for 2048 I could very
easily make that environment run a
million plus steps per second per CPU
core and at that point you can just like
you can run tens of billions of steps
worth of experiments and you don't have
to think about anything at that point
because you just run all the experiments
like the performance engineering side
makes everything else
easy let me see if I can figure out
multiprocessing while we're doing this
why it's like freezing for the Moa
it's freezing for the mobile on the
bigger
run we'll see how this
Compares so many hypers to worry about
you need autoo yeah we have that though
we have automated hyper parameter Sweep
with a good algorithm we have carbs
integration it's much better than your
typical randomer Bay
search these are already things that
I've thought about and solved in
puffer okay so here we can see this is
frozen right
you I wouldn't be working on this full
time right if I didn't think that there
was the ability to really just change an
entire field
yeah no that's not Yan kiler no way
that' be funny
though we've had some funny stream
things
happen we had uh Eugene hop in
NYU Professor hop in stream uh just in
time to see puffer lib solve one of his
RL uh one of his RL simulators like a
100 times faster than it was solved
before why is this stuck I'm trying to
think why where this could be stuck
should accumulate some stream clip for
marketing pretty cool you're working in
public like this think is really needed
yeah I mean I figure like I can be I can
work in silence or I can stream it and
have a bunch of people see it and like
this has been a great way to get people
interested in contributing as well it's
like yeah you can literally just be um
deving cool environments and like people
will show up on stream and just be like
hey I wrote this environment thing for
puffer like can you go look at the code
for it sure I'll go do code review
live heck uh in the evenings I'm often
in the Discord voice of uh you know the
puffer Discord voice like checking on
code review for people's mends and
giving us suggestions on stuff and
whatnot
trying to think how this could
possibly be
[Music]
hanging because
buff is it okay if I join the voice if
I'm not yeah you can totally join it's
open might try to do a 2048 puffer lip
version so the fun thing with puffer is
you can just use it if you have a
gymnasium M you can use it with puffer
instantly and then if you want to make
it faster right then we give you lots of
different options for how to make it
faster with
puffer all the M's are only on GitHub or
is there a separate place to search for
M's we have them on GitHub we have one
repo for the time being they're just in
uh the first party environments are an
ocean the fun thing about writing the
M's the way that we do is you get a web
build for free
like you don't have to do anything
special to get these on web cuz they're
written in C with rib so
like you just compile them for web to
web assembly and you're done and then
it's like hey I wrote breakout but I can
also play it online and like hey I wrote
snake but also I can play it online and
in fact I can take my hands off the
keyboard and the RL will play all the
snakes so we got some fun demos like
that yeah but I'd write it and see you
don't have to
I mean it depends on how familiar you
are on lowlevel stuff generally like if
you write it in Python it'll be faster
and puffer than it'll be anywhere else
if you want it to be fast then you can
write it in scon which is very much like
python but it's very fast and then if
you want to be able to play it on the
web and have it be fast and have it be a
standalone then you go to
see looks like for 9 by9 this is for go
when I cut Max steps per epis episode to
100 from 200 it is learning
better almost like it had too much
leeway to make bad
episode something's weird there Spencer
if it's getting a reward for bad moves
if it's getting a negative reward for
bad mov something's weird
there you're actually writing UI I I
mean
here let me show you how simple this
is because people do not understand when
they see this stuff like it's actually a
lot of this is very easy to get
into like here let's look at um what
pong
breakout one of these here's pong this
is 300 some odd lines this is all the
code
here is the UI at the bottom the UI is a
struct a little make function and this
is the render function right here it's
like 100 lines of code it runs on
desktop you can compile it to web
assembly and it runs on web that's
here yeah there's nothing that should be
able to Loop
here render the eval in a second waiting
for it to finish episode return has been
slowly increasing episode length has
been slowly decreasing all right
something is weird there but that's fine
for
now there's definitely something weird
there it should be able to learn to
prune inv valid moves very easily my
guess is that there's something that's
not being handled
correctly there's probably like a
specific invalid move or like
um there's probably some move that it's
not getting penalized for that it's like
able to spam or something weird like
that
TR think
why this would be
possible that like
it there's one process that's spinning
at
I don't even know why there are this
many processes there shouldn't be this
many of them
let's see this uh progress here oh look
at
that we get uh training
here and then it
spiked policy law
spiked clip crack didn't
spike is this just like too big learning
rate what the hell
here oh invalid map value hold on
there it
something invalid MTH
value there's some like bug
thing let's fix let's fix something real
quick we're going to see if we can fix
that
is I'm going use a rest from real quick
I'll be right back we'll see if we can't
find that bug it' be really good to have
this thing multiprocess
correctly be right
don't doubt that something may be screwy
but what winning 80 to 90% random
watching
render yeah we'll
see we'll see uh what it's doing that's
good though that's
progress this stck
now no it's not
stuck this one though invalid map value
and it's this is now Frozen right yeah
so it froze at 10.2 with this invalid
map value
255 how did it
find a 250
5 map
read
file I make this
so here you have this convert
map and then it gets saved like this
right go to
map oh we don't even have DOTA map do
we okay
I don't know how it's possible it's
equal to 255 unless I have the
dimensions
respawn
Towers respawn agents
I mean there could be something Jank
going on
trying to see
how the grid would get messed
255 the only other place I know where
I'm filling stuff with 255 a
bunch and there is this AI path thing
here
clue I was dumb I ignored
it I lose it oh no wait
1242 well you shouldn't be able to be at
124 but that's still a valid map value
this I'm essentially trying to figure
out there's something in here that's
screwing up in multiprocessing and I
don't know what it is I don't know why
only screws up in multi prosing but I'm
hoping I can find it with um some
compile
tools okay we're leaking tons of
MOA okay and
now this goes away
wait
net con re
there sometimes you need to do this type
of work for a bit in order to fix stuff
it's
fine read
file for
for the reason I'm doing this is because
I'm I fear that there's like some weird
memory corruption thing happening uh
that I'm not seeing because of all of
this
okay so these are good and then here's
the big
one I guess the uh the line moved hold
on
buffer okay now we should have no
more memory
furthermore we now have a clean slate to
look at this
me I don't understand this error because
like 44 is less than 512 last I checked
but I see that that could potentially
be
okay so
510 there's 26 elements though
unless I'm off by one or something but I
don't think
that was the only thing I could think
of what about ob's
map 11 by 11 by4 is this still the OB
size did I mess something up
there still 11 by 11 by4
[Music]
right and then this gives you 8
11 by 11 by 4 + 26 right
where is this the only place hold on
what what compile flags do I
have I have all of these
I have all of these
flags I'm just trying to figure out
how how it's possible for something on
the map to be invalid
there especially as a 255
like the map is getting corrupted
somehow I don't know if this is actually
the bug oh wait no it's totally the bug
look cuz you have an exit one
here you see
this so yeah this will silently
crash what if I just delete this
what if I just delete this line
let's see if that gets stuck while we go
look at our
uh our new run
here w
we look at that
something
happened radiant
carry what was happening with this run
here well I mean this looks good to
me I would like to go grab this
policy see what happened with it and
actually this one as well
at are we stuck
here how are we going to be stuck here
it's very weird here let's go grab our
um our
experiments from uh the main machine
here
okay I lose the SCP term that I was
using
before yeah
okay so this is the previous run that we
did
one I'm not seeing anything different oh
no these guys are coming
hold
though I would like to at least see the
behavior that got those scores
engage I
mean that's a three man going down
fourman going down a side
lane this guy's
stuck these guys are getting there
slowly
about to have a team fight here
right
no okay
interesting I don't really know what to
think of this
okay so here's the new
model was trained for
longer I
mean that looks good
that's a way better model that's what we
were going for
today we got to fix the multiprocessing
thing so we can do these runs fast
I want to get like a cool screenshot of
a team
M
new this is going to be mobile
just loading the new policy in it's not
a completely automated process
yet here so now I'm assassin I control
this guy uh I have like standard MOBA
controls I've got my team with me come
on these are my RL teammates they're
kind of slow come on guys you guys are
like rank plastic four or
something I'm literally going to have to
go farm something while I wait because
you guys are so slow
on except I can't really Farm very well
at low level here we'll do
Mana Tower
okay we counter their assassin cool I
mean this is like a little MOA now they
actually have a look there's their
carry oh he stunned me he actually got
me with a stun that's freaking
cool go
regen yeah solid
oh Das strike
here oh EMCC command not found that's
fine um
do how do I include
theh this m script in
found do I just need a dash ey puffer
lib
we're going to update the
website bunch of assets for
website uh Connect 4 does
not any of these
found oh this
works and take over for the puffer
right pong
Works puffer Triad works
mobile
work so the Moa does not
work and Connect 4 does not
work fure out why that
is file not
is there no game map. wome is that the
problem hold on for
what's this game.
data two Megs
nothing shouldn't even need this though
why does it have this much it's probably
because we're loading all the assets
yeah so I have to improve
that um they should be able to load
128 no difference between this and the
other one
right I don't even have a policy loaded
in this one oh
dope
LP that was
web what
and MOA is the one that doesn't work now
okay so the
Moa does work
locally so we actually do have some sort
of issue
here it would
seem do we get some sort of error
here stack overflow
yeah I had some flag here for this
didn't I
I did have some flag for
size I think I was doing anything crazy
stack
size could just be like initial memory
whatever this flag
required
mobile okay
go do we have our
team come on
come on
puffers yeah we got our
right that's
solid that's very solid
status
okay those are some nice
improvements we got to get the uh
Connect
4 thing faster so we can uh watch that
play be
interesting but yeah that's the better
MOA
opponent not an amazing MOA opponent by
any means but you know we at least we
got something reasonable that I think we
can work with and we can convert that
into much better MO opponents over time
uh we need to figure out this
vectorization
Shenanigans thing happening at the
moment
here should also commit the mo prams
before we lose
them
MOA um
fixed we
freeze no
does this fix
it the thing that we
me 500k
train very
nice okay so there's some weird Edge
case thing that we have not caught
correctly at least now it it doesn't
like hard fail um we'll see if it screws
up training or anything
few issues remaining with environment
speed and the
like that we need to
fix I'm leave this here for
now it's 5:00 P p.m. be right back I'm
going to use a
restroom I'm going to come back I'm
going to see if I can do some per fixes
on the
MOBA get this thing a little bit faster
and then we should be good and I don't
know if we'll run a sweep or how we'll
treat this but we will do some sort of
experiments overnight on this be right
[Music]
see ooh
uh that's
weird oh it's fine we didn't uh we
didn't
rebuild that's my
bad
all right we'll see if that's stable in
a
we're stuck at 10.2 still aren't
we how do that
work we got the 44 million over here so
how's this
there we
go all right
well we're not stuck at 10.2 we're stuck
at
12.3 big
Improvement why the heck does it work
here I ran it with multiprocessing on
there are no other possible places it
should be able to be stuck
here
weird maybe we uh we figure this out in
the process of doing a little bit of
perf
profiling and there's the main annoyance
at the moment I think if we fix this
everything else is good
well all
right be right back and then we'll fix
this I don't know what's up with it
local so it's plenty fast or should be
plenty
fast there's no reason for it to be slow
600k on the slow box should be like 2
million on the past box
Flags this might literally be compile
Flags
there's just simply no way that this
should be 44%
is this scon just being terrible or like
what
I don't
understand uh what's the what the hell
is wrong with this
I swear it stands for I don't know what
the
[ __ ] I don't know maybe before we solve
AGI we can solve
um
indenting or pasting in Vim that would
be
either the perf test is wrong or it's
like something screwy here let's
see okay
12 1.2 million
wait no this is steps yeah times 10 cuz
right did you write your own C version
of linear LS layer plus lstm
yeah we have comms as
well you want to play with them
now available on Discord dot well not
discord. GP puffer just puffer Dogg
there you go so you can play this guy
and your teammates will come after you
using their little CN lstm policy there
you go and eventually they'll fight in
mid come on
puffers here there's the other team
coming here's our team
going let's here this guy's strong right
let's uh save the
oops I got to get back to the fight to
still gives me
800k
I don't even know how it's possible it's
still 26% with two of these
environments now there it goes Frozen
again
I actually can't think of anything that
would cause a process like this to
freeze
especially not something that would
cause it to freeze multiprocess and not
sanitizer there's not even anything
happening
across but like I'm not doing anything
that's
actually multi-threaded or anything like
that
I mean I can put this in but like I'm
not even using
threads unless something like I don't
even have dependencies that could be
using threads that I'm aware
frozen yeah well the thing is like it
runs the end runs native it doesn't run
with
multiprocessing like it'll run 10
million steps and then freeze
I don't know why like I have no idea
what the heck could be causing that you
know does it work multi-threaded how am
I supposed to
know I mean I'm not doing anything I can
think of that would make it not work
mult
regardless objects are inherited between
processes
environments we're making the
environments
on the subprocess anyways
right standard
vectorization the fail in
cereal I don't know we don't really
support like cereal doesn't really work
at the moment for
um puffer native M I got to fix
that and I can run it
it's also running way slower than the
perf tests indicate it should be
running I mean I actually can't think of
anything that would cause this at
Frozen at 10.2 without even Computing
obs
I can't see how it would possibly be
this
7.2 well there's no error
print you changed it yeah that doesn't
matter it's not deterministic when it
freezes
it yeah I don't set terminals
anywhere so it shouldn't be able to
be screwed with
is using unsigned Char for terminals
correct
I'm like trying to think what the hell
this could be
I mean is it like some memory bug that's
not getting caught because of
forever I I think I just have the
thing oh you know what this is
here there
dude what the [ __ ] how do I get this
these
can I just do a dress
sanitizer will this
work how about just this one and I have
one sanitizer
scon what do I got to do for one
sanitizer why is it always that the C
works and then the [ __ ] python
binding somehow screws it
whatever re BRB rewriting all of modern
software and
I'm just like I don't know what the hell
this could possibly be
I'm trying to think like how I can even
debug this
does it
crash when I do one end even with just
one M
multiprocess trying to get
multiprocessing working on the latest
it's something screwy with uh the Moa
it's not
multi-processing it's just randomly
hanging welcome
Spencer I'm going to jump off of this do
some stuff for like half an hour and
then uh I'll check in on go or whatever
in a bit I just want to try a couple
last
things I will set up some experiments to
run regardless it's just obnoxious cuz
like I mean look it's hanging even
there I don't understand how it's
possible that the exact same code
doesn't work in a subprocess
so
here we do with this right
typ OB
type
thanks bet Star Puffer indeed star repo
helps me very
i' would be willing to be less human if
I didn't have to [ __ ] deal with this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
hell all right well we found something
that causes the same hanging Behavior
which is passing bad buffer or passing
different buffer actually that's weird
it it's got to be Memory corruption on
actions
evil memory
corruption on python to scon on data
transfer yeah this is the same thing
that you were dealing with with actions
it's [ __ ]
evil we need I need to add some guard
checks to the new
API that's evil evil
evil half a million
train on the
Moa I'm trying to think what I even want
to run for sweeps
we're not doing the fixes tonight we
know what it is we know we have to add
those checks we know it produces
hangs the other M's good it depends on
the
will'll make it architecturally
impossible to have that bug
again get rid of this
this
now we'll see if this produces anything
um anything
okay well we figured out the evil evil
bug that's the last really evil bug with
the new uh
API couple more things to do but we got
at least a reasonably competent MOBA
model trained
today and deployed
it's not amazing or anything but you do
actually get the agents fighting each
other in mid which is what we
work I don't understand why this does
not show up in the stupid
how many games of break how many games
of uh breakout does it play
right
16,000 times real Time That's crazy
how did you pick the name
puffer it's like the puffer fish up
there you see
him you can play with the puffer too at
puffer
Dogg you just hold shift you can take
over for the train agent and see if you
can do any
better well why the puffer fish I mean
what would you do if you were going to
start a company that did like
complicated Tooling in a niche domain
that's really hard to explain it's like
I'm not not going to have a logo that
has anything to do with that no here
have a puffer fish it's funny and it's
memeable this actually feels like a fair
game as well as of pong it doesn't feel
[ __ ] like the original Atari games
do with all the rappers and [ __ ] like
you actually have very precise control
here puffer fish ball is funny yeah we
did it for breakout as well oops you can
hold shift for this one
too this one is
harder I got to get nowhere to like fix
some stuff on this or I'm probably I'm
going to have to do it he's linked me
the code um
yeah exactly so I'm probably going to
have to do
it big deal unless you want to but it's
not really a huge
deal so we got this one right uh we also
have this Connect 4 one where we need a
better agent versus this I think Jack is
going to do that
Enduro going to be a
meme yeah got to finish
that we upgraded the graphics on Triad a
little bit as well I got to update the
thumbnails
probably but yeah there you
go let me make sure my Wanda Bay weeps
are good
me
cool we have our carb sweep
cool all right I'm going to call it
there
um you
can try out this stuff at puffer G you
can get all the code at puffer ai.
github.io right here is the
GitHub go ahead and start the GitHub if
you haven't already please actually do
that it really does help me out a lot um
that and followers on X are the only
really two growth metrics I track for
the project you can also join us on
discord.gg puffer if you want to get
involved with contributing to the
project and developing some of these
environments you really just need an
engineering background as all um the
reinforcement learning side of things
you kind of pick up along the way no big
deal um yeah so I'm going to go hop off
of this I'm going to do a couple things
and then I'll probably jump into the
Discord voice for a bit to help
troubleshoot uh whatever problems people
have on custom M thanks all and